What I did yesterday or Monday.
Westers describe the first law of thermodynamics is that led me to my and do
what the context was.
They're going to study a system that's sober thermodynamic system and for all
our purposes you can imagine that to be someone more the ideal gas trapped
inside this
Visteon and cylinder combination.
We poured some weights,
I'd maybe some sand on top to keep the Piston we had.
We wanted the gas has a certain pressure and a certain volume and we represent
that by a point in this diagram
that defines the state.
Yeah,
that's called the state of the gas.
I'd have microscopic level.
The state is very complicated,
right?
That are 10 to the 23 atoms or molecules zipping around.
We're not interested in such detailed properties,
be wanting to look at bulk macroscopic properties of its pressure and volume is
a complete tear.
That's all you need.
I think I reminded you that you don't need a third axis for temperature because
we have this equation,
PV equals NRT,
so if you know p and V,
you don't need temperature as another variable.
That's called the equation of state.
You can use this all the time.
Whenever over the gas has got a pressure and volume,
feel free to use PV equals NRT.
All right,
so here's the gas and then I want to change its state.
And I explained to you that unlike particles who stayed can change as fast as
you like.
You cannot change the state of a gas abruptly because if you take half the
weight off,
the top of the piston will fly off.
That'll be PD.
And when the gas is not in equilibrium,
different parts of it will have different density,
different pressure.
You cannot represent that complicated state as a point in this plane.
So what we want to do is to make changes which are slow enough for us to follow.
So one way to do that is to take one grain of sand,
one grain of sand,
then you lower the pressure a little bit,
the piston will move up a little bit more.
What means what bigger volume?
Lower pressure.
The gas don't come there.
And then you can take off another grain.
And by making the grain smaller and smaller,
you can make this dots closer and closer.
It's going to take you a long time,
but in principle you can make the guests move on some path that is a
thermodynamic process.
This process is always near equilibrium.
You never disturb it too from equilibrium and it's called a quasi static.
That means not quite static
but as slow as you like and it is called reversible.
Reversible means that you can also go right back to bed.
Ukraine.
If you look at grain out piston expanse,
you put the grain back listing contracts so you can go down this way or you can
go up this way.
I have just chosen to,
let's say go down like this.
When that happens,
we want to say the following thing about the state of the gas before and after
every point in the PV diagram,
the gas has something called the internal energy.
Okay,
and the characteristic of the internal energy is it's called a state variable.
That's a very important concept.
Yes.
A state variable depends on where you are,
the Pv Diagram,
what your status.
It does not depend on the history,
does not depend on all the things that gas has gone through in his life.
If you're telling me you are here,
then we may associate with that point and energy that doesn't look into the
history of that gas.
That energy is nothing other than the Kennedy Energy.
You remember that is three halves,
Katie Porter,
Adam and Adam's.
That's the internal energy.
You can also write this three halves and our T.
Hey,
did they count the molecules and news?
Boltzmann constant rd.
Count the number of moles and use the gas constitute the same thing.
But our t NRT is PV.
So if you like,
you can also write it this week
that shows you very clearly.
The internal energy is uniquely determined by PV and PMV determine the product
PV.
So it eats point in this diagram,
the gas is a certain energy.
That energy is simply the one half MV squared for each molecule.
You add it all up.
That's the total energy.
Okay,
so you can write it in many different ways.
Now,
the first law of thermodynamics asked the following question,
if I wanted to change the energy of this gas,
how can I do it?
That are two ways to change the energy of the gas and the total change in you,
meaning you at the end,
minus you at the beginning.
But these are to nearby points is either the heat input
minus the work done by the gas.
Uh,
let me write it as capital p DB.
Sometimes you write it as Delta Q minus Delta w
yeah,
that's the first law.
So you have to take some time.
Understand what it says.
Notice from this formula here,
the energy of an ideal gas and only an ideal gases.
That's the only thing we are going to talk about is a function only of
temperature.
If you know what the temperature of the gas,
you know the candidate,
the molecules,
and if the number is constant,
the NTDs determined energy depends only on the temperature for an ideal gas.
So basically when I say how can it change the energy of the gas,
I'm asking how can I raise the temperature?
One obvious way is this,
put it on a hot plate with a slightly hotter than the gas.
Then the heat will flow from the hot plate to the gas that's called heating up
the gas they had.
You don't see anything happening right occurring at a molecular level.
The molecules in the hot plate or on average moving faster than the molecules
and the gas and during the collision Kennedy going to do will be transferred
from the hot plate to the gas.
That invisible flow people used to think of as the calorie fluid but now we know
is just molecular candidate energy transferred from the molecules and the plate,
the molecules and the guests that this guy,
this delta w the plus with a plus sign at the w is the work done by the guests
and minus of that is the work done on the gas
and that means if you want to increase the temperature of the gas you're also
totally,
you can do the following push down on the piston.
If you push down on the piston,
you're reducing the volume.
Delta v is negative minus beetle is positive.
That law also increased the energy of the gas art.
If you take a grain of sand out and the piston moves upwards,
the gas works against the environment and it pays for it through its internal
energy because then p Delta t will be positive and this thing will be a negative
contribution to the internal energy.
So there are two ways to change the energy of the gas.
One is a way you can actually see by moving up and down the piston.
You can see somebody moving it.
It's a macroscopic motion of something you can see that's called a work.
Then on the gas,
other one is energy transfer at a molecular microscopic level,
which is what we call heat.
And the first law says the total change in the internal energy is the summer of
two numbers.
First one is the heat input and the second one is the work done.
Okay,
so what I did for you last name was the practice calculation in with I took a
gas here,
went along and ISO therapy,
that means temperatures are constant.
That's the meaning of the isotherm.
And I want to go from some initial point to some final points.
So this is volume be and pressure p one this is p two and p two and I want to
find the work done by the gas during this expansion.
Well Pete Times Delta v you can see it's really that shaded area here because
it's a rectangle of p and with Delta v P Delta v is just the area under the
graph that you follow.
So the work then the sum of all the infinite decimal works.
Yes,
the pressure as a function of volume times DV from the starting volume for the
ending volume.
What is p as a function of be at constant temperatures and our tea over v
now I'm using the fact that at every point PBS and r t p is NRT over v and this
is a logarithm and we all know how to do the integral is log of the upper limit
minus log of the lower lip.
So that's though the first successful calculation of work done.
You can take the gas on any path you like.
You know as long as you knew the pressure at each volume,
you integrate the function from the left limit to the right limit.
That's the word that what isothermal process is particularly easy because the
pressure is inversely proportional to volume and you do that integral.
This is the work that for example,
the gas expense or double the value a temperature 300 Kelvin.
The work done is number of malls,
gas constant,
300 log have to multiply all those things.
That's the work done by the guests.
If that is a work done by the gas,
we can also say the following,
the internal energy change is zero,
right?
That the trick question I told you to watch out for,
if you're going at a constant temperature,
you don't change the internal energy that the change,
that internal energy is zero.
It follows at every step.
Delta Q is equal to Delta w this quantity we call the belt at w.
That for the work done by the gas is also equal to the total heat input to the
gas.
We indicate that by drawing a little arrow like this,
you just,
the way we like to show the heat flows into the gas.
Okay?
Did you guys understand physically what's happening?
You take this gas,
you keep it on a reservoir at temperature t one it stuck at that temperature.
If you take a grain of sand,
gas is expanding.
Normally when the gas expands,
it does work and it's energy will go down.
It'll cool down.
What do you not letting it cool down because you're pumping in heat from below,
maintaining it at the temperature.
So this process you should visualize as the piston,
which some waves sipping on a plate,
a temperature t one you take off a grain of sand,
it moves up a little bit,
but you don't let it cool down because you send in heat from below maintaining
it at that temperature.
For example,
you've got this computer ad,
right?
You blow air on your keyboard to blow off the dust.
You know when you blow the air out,
the canned cools down.
It cools sound because the compressed air is working against the atmosphere as
it comes out.
And therefore it loses internal energy and it cools down.
That's because you're not giving it enough time to absorb the heat from the
room.
If you like.
They erode slow enough so that in the process of expansion in your tries to cool
down,
but the room pumps more,
some more heat than of course there can will not cooler.
But you know that's not the purpose of buying candy.
You don't want to buy canned there so you can really sit at room temperature.
You don't care if it cools down.
We just want the gas to come out really fast.
So if you don't know,
I love what heat to come in and expand the guests,
we'll call them.
Cause that's also where the universe Coldstone prostate expansion.
All right,
so here's a simple problem where you can do many things.
You can find the change in energy from start to finish.
Zero work done.
You find by integrating PDB and the heat input is equal.
The work done because there is no change in energy.
This is all the stuff I did last time.
I also did a couple of other topics.
I'll just remind you of what they are.
I said we can define a specific heat for a gas.
Now normally a specific heat is the number of calories to raise one gram or one
kilogram,
but one degree.
But for gas,
what matters is not the number of grams,
but number of moles.
You have already seen it here.
The energy of the gas is not proportional to the grams of gas you have,
but the number of atoms you have or the number of moles you have.
So we defined specific heat to be the heat needed to produce a certain
temperature change.
For one mole,
you take a mole of gas and you,
you hit the guy and you see how many calories do I need to get an increase at
one degree,
but that turns out to be insufficient.
This data with the,
that's not have a unique value
than someone telling me why it's not sufficient information.
Do you remember from last time?
Yes.
In other words,
when I take a solid and I say find the specific key,
take one gram of solid pumping some heater,
the temperature goes up by one degree.
Keep track of the calories you're done for a gas.
It turns out if you took this gas in the cylinder and you pump in some calories,
it's going to try to heat up and when it tries to heat a bit,
we also expand.
Yeah.
When the expanding
than some of the energy that you pump in the form of heat.
Some of it's turning into work to push the piston out.
The part that goes to the internal energy,
the part that really hits it,
the gas is now less because you put in some heat from below.
You lose them here to the expansion.
So what goes into 10 the internal energy,
which is what controls the temperature is less than the heat you put in.
So if the gas expands during the heating process,
that's a certain energy loss due to work you have to take into account.
On the other hand,
another other person can do the same experiment or the gas,
but put a pin here is the piston cannot move.
Then of course it cannot do any work and all the heat you put in goes into
internal energy.
That gas will heat up more readily
for a solid,
we don't worry about it because the expansion of a solid is such a tiny fraction
of its volume when the temperature changes,
but the fact that a chunk of copper when you heat is also expanding I Guess
Universe,
I guess the atmospheric pressure is a negligible effect.
The Delta v is so small for a solid B,
ignore it.
For the gas,
it's very important.
Therefore for the gas that are two kinds of specific heat,
you'd in fact you can define many definitions.
The two common ones are,
one is CV,
which is Delta Q or Delta t at constant volume.
That's the beauty that in calculus.
The other one is p with a delta Q over Delta t at constant pressure.
So let me,
did I one more time these two specific keys because it's worth going over this
again and again.
The key to all of this is the first law,
the first law written after transposition.
It looks like this.
Let's put Delta Q on one side and the other stuff on the right hand side.
In the first case at constant volume,
that is no p Delta B term because Delta v zero that for Delta Q over Delta t is
equal to Delta.
You over Delta t and for one mole you remember you is three over two and r d but
in this one but one more so do you d t is a simple bit of it to have this
function with respect to eat which just three over two r.
What do you notice about this formula?
Is the specific heat of a one mole of a gas best independent on what the gases
as long as they'd say monoatomic gas.
It doesn't matter what the motto Adam is.
It could be hybrid,
it could be helium,
it doesn't matter.
That's why we like to think about the smaller specific heater specific heat per
mole.
You got an answer that's universal.
If it looks specifically at for gram than one gram of hydrogen and one gram of
helium won't have the same specific heat because they don't have the same number
of Adams.
Would if you count in malls.
The beauty of the formula is this number is true for all ideal gases.
Whereas if you look specifically the copper or silver that iron,
it varies from material to material.
That's figurative,
ideal gases.
It's very simple.
You don't need to look at a table.
He understands that for all ideal guests it's very important.
It's a monotonic gas,
which is the point like Adam with only moves but doesn't have any internal
structures so it can spin and rotate and vibrate.
If it can do that,
that other contribution to energy,
we're not going there.
Now let's calculate CP.
CP is Delta Q over Delta t at constant pressure,
so now you cannot ignore this term,
so delta you
from what I did before,
we'll be CV times delta t plus.
That is a new term.
P Delta t is Delta FPV because these constant,
if pizza constant,
the change in Pv,
the same as p times change in vi but PV equals Rt.
So CV,
Delta t plus our Delta t
to divide every site by Delta t and take Delta Q over Delta t than CP will be CV
plus are and that's a very famous formula
and you should understand why specifically that constant pressure is more than
specific either constant volume.
Think about that.
If the gas is stuck at a given volume,
it's easier to heat it up because all the heat goes into internal energy.
If there's a constant pressure,
you're letting the piston move up and some of the heat is being paid to move the
piston,
only the rest is going to change the internal energy.
That's why CP is always bigger than CV,
but an ideal gas CPCV plus r and this number,
Gamma is defined as CP oversee
for an ideal get.
This is always the definition of gamma,
whether it's an ideal gas or not.
What an ideal gas.
We can calculate CPO over CV which is three over two are blessed and other that
are divided by three over two r which is five over three
so gamma is not always five over three.
You should be aware of that,
but for ideal gas,
Gamma is fire over three.
So this is a view of what I did last time,
but I'm very eager that you guys should be on top of this and it's worth doing
it one more time.
But now I'm going to consider some more processes where I want to find the work
done.
So maybe I'll start fresh here.
Let's take the following
process.
I start here,
I go on an ice up there among here.
Then I go backwards at constant pressure.
Glen,
right below this point.
Then I go straight up.
You can ask what does the work done in this process?
The word done in the curvy part of it is all of this
that's in the park aid a B
in the part B c
we're done is the area of this rectangle,
but it's counted as negative because the gas is being compressed are if you like
it said some constant pressure,
but the change in volume is negative for every step.
So even though the Word Ben is said to be the area,
you got to keep track of sign.
If you're compressing the gas,
PW is negative.
Therefore in the pot BC we mistake away the shaded region
and ca no work is done because volume is not changing.
Eddie out of the vertical line is zero,
so you can see that in this full cycle.
When I go from a,
from a to B to c back to a,
the work done is the area enclosed by the loop in the PD plan.
That's the videos for this.
Now we say the work done in a cycle.
This is a symbol we like to use.
This curly thing on integrated means taking that only close loop.
What do you guys have to be a little careful when you write this because
somebody else can do the following thing to the gas.
Exactly the opposite.
Come down like this,
go down like this and go down like that.
Go up like that.
The opposite way.
In this case,
the work done is considered positive because the the part of it,
a B is taller than the BC it point wise,
so the network is positive.
Here it's the same.
I want to work but no network is negative.
You've got to be careful that you describe the sense in which you do the loop.
So the same loop as a geometrical figure as the same area,
but the work done by the gas is positive in this case and they get them in this
case,
and you can use common sense to find out if it's positive or negative.
But here's another very interesting result.
Let's go to the full cycle
and ask what's the change in you?
Yes.
PV In the beginning and the end of the theme [inaudible] right.
His answer
was Pv is the same.
And what generally,
even if there's not an ideal gas,
it's a gas made up of whatever you like is any system.
If you were to turn the system back to the same state,
the internal energy returns to that value.
That's what I meant by internal energy.
It doesn't depend on the history of the guests.
For example,
you can take the cylinder,
you leave it alone.
I measured the energy.
I go outside the room and come back.
In the meantime,
you took it on a loop and brought it back.
I will not know and I don't care because as far as I'm concerned,
if p and g are back to where they are,
the gases back to editors,
energies back to where it is.
So the change in the internal energy is zero.
That means the work done and the heat input are the same.
So let's be very clear.
If you guys do problems,
I don't want you to lose points for sign mistake.
W is also always the word done and Q is always the heat into the gas.
So this is a gas here which has done some work and some heat that's being pulled
into the gas and the two have to be equal because the energy doesn't change in
the end.
No,
that leads to a very,
very subtle and interesting point.
That is a very clear notion of what does the energy in the gas.
That's a unique answer.
There is no notion of what does the heat and the gas.
You look at a gas and you cannot do this is the heat and the gas.
That makes no sense.
Trying to understand why because if you say that some amount of heat and the
gas,
okay,
whatever you want some number.
I do the cycle and the come back to exactly where I am.
I've put in some amount of heat Q which is non zero,
so if there is anything called the heat and the gas,
it has changed by an I'm on cue.
That's where there is no notion of heat in the gas or to work in the gas.
There's only energy in the gas,
a state variable return,
Sue's original value and when you go on a close loop the change should add up to
zero.
That's not true for work.
That's not true for heat,
but it's true for the difference that defines an internal state video.
Okay.
Now I'm going to consider a new process which is a special importance to the
processes I've considered so far or isothermal at constant pressure is called
ISO Barteck
and I don't know the name for constant volume,
but no work is done a constant volume.
I'm going to consider it the last process,
very,
very important.
It's called Eddie A.
Backtick
did process is in which the gas changes his volume,
but it's completely thermally isolated belt.
That Q is zero.
You wrapped this guy in a blanket and you do do it.
No heat can flow into the gas or odor.
The gas,
that's called an 80 robotic process.
Isothermal is quite different.
Isothermal you keep it on a hot plate at a given temperature and as the volume
changes,
say as the volume increases,
he'd comes in from below.
Odd.
When you compress it and you don't want it to heat up,
heat is rejected below.
But this is not the case here in the adiabatic process.
If you let the gas expand,
you thermally isolated from everything.
So you should think about what will happen to a gas.
If I start here,
that's what isothermal is.
What do you think will happen?
So let's draw a few ice up.
Terminus.
This is temperature safety fall to 300
this is Steve equal.
Do One more than 300 or less than 300
can you guys?
Yes.
Less.
And why do I say less?
You take any point here.
It's got the same volume but lower pressure.
So p Times v is less.
So this may be the equal to 200 if I start here,
no way.
Let the gas expand Eddie a badly.
That means it pull out the grains of sand,
the gas expense that gives you atmosphere,
but no heat is allowed to come in.
Think about what that means.
Gas is pushing the piston,
gas is doing some work and pay for it through its own internal energy.
Internal Energy will go down.
That means temperature will go down.
So what you will be doing is you'll be cascading down from one ice attempt to
another plummeting down in temperature till you come and stop somewhere at a
lower temperature.
So an Eddie about Dick Process will cross from one ice up there and to the next,
to the next,
to the next changing temperature.
Another way to say this is that the drop in pressure,
but given drop an increase in volume,
it would be more precipice.
But I Padick because it's expanding,
but there's no energy coming into the form of pizza.
Pressure drops more precipitants so it won't be PV equals the constant.
And the question is what is it?
What is the equation for an idea biotic process,
what is p as the function of B?
That's what we want to ask now.
Okay,
so whenever you have any such question in thermodynamics up to this point,
the only law we know is the first law of thermodynamics.
So you have to go back to that.
So so far
I've driven home the point that every question I and mechanics can be traced
back to Newton's law that are no new laws.
But when you come to terms or dynamics and you study heat and temperature,
that is new stuff in the first law of thermodynamics is called the law because
there is no way you can derive it from Newtonian laws.
It's a new concept.
So let's ask what is p as a function of B given that Delta Q is zero.
So what?
What's our strategy going to be?
How would you even begin this?
Do you have some idea what you might do?
This is a tough question.
So even if you give a wrong answer,
that's fine.
How do I calculate the relation of P to B given the Delta Q is zero.
Yes.
[inaudible] Delta
pressure.
Right side.
Okay,
so let me,
let me write down everything he said.
When I say Delta Q is zero,
your first reaction has to go back to the first law and write Delta Q as Delta,
you plus p Delta v
and set that equal to zero
but Delta you his CV times Delta t
less p Delta v is zero.
Yeah,
by the Bay Delta use CB Delta t four one more.
I'm going to consider one mole of gas.
Now this is another thing you people turn.
Understand the way in which pressure falls with temperature is going to be the
same or that I consider one more or two malls at 10 moles
rated with two changes will not be dependent on how many moles I took.
So if you want,
you can take and malts and put an n here,
you'll find everywhere in and will come and cancel out.
No,
P N R T B.
So maybe I'll do it this way for you guys if you want to put an end back there,
but you will find end camps and so does the equation cause NCV,
Delta t blessing n r t Delta v Over v equals zero.
So the answer doesn't depend on how many moles you took.
So I will take one mole for my calculation.
Think about what this says.
Divide everything by,
let's see,
you weight everything by t good CV over our Delta t over t plus Delta v over B
is zero.
This is telling you that as you change your volume and you're coming down this
graph of ID,
a backtick expansion,
when you go from there to there,
that's the change in temperature such that the change in temperature by the
temperature plus the change in volume divided by the volume should add up to
zero.
That is a condition of no heat flow.
So it relates to change in t change in v.
What I would have ideally liked is a change in p due to change in B,
but what comes more naturally,
it's a change in t over change in B.
But let's worry about that later because we got PB,
what's rt?
We can always swap the temperature for pressure in the end.
So let's just take this definition
so every change,
remember now you understand you go from one point to the neighboring point,
that's the plant in temperature.
That's where Delta t will be negative and Delta will be positive and these
numbers will of course cancel.
No,
let's add all the changes.
That's call it doing the integral to the integral of that from start to finish
through the integral of that from start to finish and that integral of zero is
still zero.
Yeah.
This tells me CV over our flames log of t two over t one less logs of veto over
B one zero
no,
you got to go back and think of Bodie logarithms and realized that I can write
it as a log of t two over t one raised to the power CVO.
What are times to be two over V one
is equal to zero.
You just come by and all the logarithms and realize the log of x to the power
and his end log x.
So that is the same as this no log of something.
A zero means that something is one because log of one is zero.
So we rewrite the final expression I got up there by saying t two
over t one they used to see the old r Times v two over v one is equal to one
and we usually write it as follows.
We say t to race to the CD over our v two to the power of one is t one race to
the CV?
I'm sorry,
can you one race to see the over r Times v one
so this is the relation between the temperature and the volume.
Yes.
[inaudible]
you could do that.
That's correct.
You could write down three halves if you like.
At the moment,
I'm trying to keep it general.
If it was a gas for which a CV was not,
rehabs are,
all of this would still be true,
but he's quite right.
What an ideal monoatomic gas CVO rod would be just to be over too.
So what it's telling you is that when the gas expands,
the temperature falls.
I already told you that.
It's telling you exactly how it falls.
It tells you the tea to some Strange Power Times v is constant during the
process.
Now if you want to know what happens to the pressure,
you can do the following.
You remember PV equals Rt.
Therefore you can rate this t o s okay,
that are many ways to write this.
I'm going to write it in another way and you guys see if we can follow this.
T Two d two to the power r oversee be physical.
Just t one.
You wonder the polar odd oversee me.
You believe that that just a mathematical trick.
If I,
if that is true.
This is true.
You know how they went from here to here.
How did they go from here to here?
You have an idea.
Um,
you take the,
you take our overseas power exec take raise both sites.
The power odd oversee V it's cooked up so that CVO overall goes away.
And the auto where CV falls on V two.
So here's another way to write it if you like.
I'll tell you why I rated this way because t two is just Pete to meet to the,
let me combine that one,
beat two with this right and one plus odd over CB.
Then I can show you just p one do you want the flower one plus odd over CV show
you owe me a brick.
That PV is not tea but it's rt but art will cancel.
So I didn't bother with that
and this don't draw the box around this yet.
I will write it in a way that's very,
very standard.
And if you remember your high school days,
you may remember it's written as p Two v two to the gamma is equal to p one the
wonder the gamma,
but gamma is just one plus r Oversee v which you can see is equal to CB plus our
oversee v and that is CP over CV.
So there's gamma is really CPO oversea
for an ID biotic process,
p Two v two the gamma speed when we wanted the gamma.
That's one way to write it,
but I will also expect you to know that you can also write it in terms of
temperature as temperature times volume raise to a strange power is equal to
constant before and after.
Okay.
Any questions?
So what we have done is found pressure as a function of volume on an idea Batek
curve.
So I'm now going to do one last ingredient for the rest of the stuff,
which is the following.
I'm going to calculate the work done in an aerobatic process from here to here.
This is one,
this is true.
This is not a nice determine which books like that or it's an antiemetic
process.
What's the work done in adiabatic price?
Let's calculate that work done is equal to integral PDV
pdf to be DV.
But remember PB the gamma is a constant.
Do you guys understand the relation of writing PV to the gamma?
Equal to constant is the same as saying be when we went to the gamma speed to
through the gamma.
That means you can pick any point on that path.
And with Pete at that point,
times be at that point,
the power gamma will be a fixed number.
That number is c.
In other words,
this c can be,
can you want to be wanted the gamma,
if you like,
odd p Two v two to the gamma,
if you like p three B through the gamma.
If three is another point on the trajectory,
it's convenient to call that invariant product of p res Pv.
We raised the cameras,
see,
because then we can do the integral as DV over overreach.
The gamma constancy here
from v one to v two
okay,
and this is a pretty simple integral.
You guys know that the extra,
the end integral is actually the n plus one over n plus one so to the,
to the gamma minus one over gamma minus ones
because this is really beat at the minus gamma.
Did I get it wrong here?
I think I got it wrong.
Sorry.
All right.
One minus gamma one minus gamma over one minor scale
because we do the minus gamma,
the V is equal to v two the minus gamma plus one or minus gamma plus one.
Right x to the n integral is extra the n plus one over n plus one and happens to
be minus gamma here.
Okay,
now watch this.
This constant I said can be written as any of these numbers,
but let me write Ben and multiplies.
This limited is p Two v two to the gamma.
Can you see happens if I do that?
Try to do this in your head when the seat see multiplies all of this.
When see multiplies this guy,
let me write the concept of speed to be two to the gamma.
That gives me a p two B two to the gamma combines with be two to the one minus
gamma to give me just a bit too.
Likewise,
see multiplying this one when the same,
see multiplies this.
Let's write CSP one.
We wanted the gamma and we'll finders that
and people like to rewrite this by changing the sign everywhere as p One v one
minus p Two v two over gamma minus one because gamma minus one is the positive
quantity.
So this is the work done in an anti biotic process.
So what?
What's been going on?
Let's think about what I've been doing.
I told you that there is a new process called aerobatic.
Very important process in which the system is not allowed to exchange heat with
the outside world.
Delta Q equals to zero is a condition relating Delta u and P,
Delta t and the changes are correlated and the effect of adding up all the
changes,
namely doing the integral is this one,
namely temperature.
The CD overall times B two does not change along the path.
So if you take any two points,
that combination of temperature and volume doesn't change.
Then since PBX will do essentially tea,
you can also write it as pressure times volume to the power gamma doesn't
change.
So I'm saying you can call all of that equal some constant sea.
The sea is not a universal constantly like velocity of light for the given gas
on a given experiment.
It does not change.
Acid goes through Eddie about expansion,
so don't think of it as a universal constant on that trajectory,
on their id badge,
the curve.
It's a constant.
It's like saying kinetic energy plus potential energy is a constant.
It's not a constant,
you can look up in a book.
It depends on what your particular is doing.
But for that particle in those conditions,
candidate was potential ads to a particular constant.
We call the total energy.
Likewise Pv,
the gamma is a constant for this particular gas.
Okay,
so all this was actually a preparation for something else
and that's what we are going to discuss now.
So between now and the end of this course,
we're going to discuss
the second law of thermodynamics.
So we have done all we want to do with the first law.
So you guys should be able to be given various graphs in the PD plan,
find the work done and going from here to there,
find the change in internal energy,
find the change in,
find the heat added and so on.
I hope you can do such problems,
but they're all going to be one of these formulas.
Hey,
there's going to be idea Barrick or constant pressure,
constant temperature.
So you just plug the numbers in,
keep track of the science by using common sense.
All right,
so now we come to the last part of thermodynamics,
which is to me the one of the most beautiful parts of them are dynamics,
which starts out with asking the following question.
There are certain things in this world that are perfectly allowed but don't seem
to happen.
Let's take many examples.
Take the jewel experiment.
You take a cylinder of water with a paddle that can spin and you put some weight
around the pulley and the way it goes down paddled,
spins,
the water heats up.
You take a movie of that and the movie is so fine,
it can even cat individual molecules.
Now you play the movie backwards.
So you watched the movie being played back and what do you find?
Suddenly the weight starts moving up and spins the other way and the water cools
down.
This is not in violation of any of the laws you have learned,
including the first law of thermodynamics.
Because when the weight went down and the water heated up,
some amount of work was done on the gas and the on the water and the energy of
the water went up in the reverse process.
The energy of the water went down and instead the weight went up.
So work was done by the system.
But that
doesn't seem to happen.
If the weight comes down,
you can wait all day.
Or let me give you another example.
Take a chunk of wood.
The slider there,
sorry.
It was not a piece of work and it didn't stop.
See,
this is why I don't do demonstrations because even the simplest demonstration I
have done a doesn't work.
So that's where some of us become theoretical physicist.
I did a demonstration where some trolley supposed to shoot a little marble.
All the marvel had to do was come down and even that didn't work.
So I don't do demonstration.
Well let's try.
This incident is there.
I give it a push and it stops.
Take the movie of that,
play it backwards.
You will find suddenly,
you know the table heats up a little bit due to friction.
The table can cool down and the is that it can move backwards.
Speaking of speed,
right to why did they laugh?
You have no reason to laugh right now because it doesn't violate anything you
have learned other than your daily experience because in the reverse process,
every atom,
every atomic thing in the desk that started moving is made to stop,
turn around and moving backwards direction and every coalition between atoms on
the desk and atoms on the razor will obey all the laws of mechanics.
For example,
if you have a planet going around the sun,
if you stop the planet and Universe,
the velocity,
we'll go the opposite way and the opposite motion is incomplete.
Our Card with Newton's laws,
in fact that maybe some of the solar system where the planet actually goes the
other way,
it doesn't violate any and all the movies which are played backwards at the very
microscopic level,
there's nothing that says it cannot happen and yet it does not happen.
Here's another thing that does not happen.
I take a
box and I put some gas molecules on one side and there's a partition holding
them in that side.
Then I remove this partition and the way the little bitch,
then I know the gas fields up.
Now take,
that's like perfume leaking out of the bottle.
Now take a movie of these molecules when they go from here to here and play the
movie backwards.
What happened when you play the movie backwards?
Let's say this guy was moving like this.
The instant you play the movie back,
well in the backwards moving and start going the other way and slowly the whole
thing will untangle itself and end up here.
That also will not happen.
We all know that if you go to the room and they released some gas from one site,
it can fill the room,
but it's not ever going to come back and yet it doesn't violate any laws because
if I made a movie and played it backwards in every microscopic interactions
between molecules,
there'll be no violation of any of the laws of nature.
That doesn't happen.
Here's another thing that doesn't happen.
I take a chunk of some heart copper and they take a chunk of some coal,
copper,
hot,
cold.
I just put them on top of each other.
Come back in an hour.
It's becomes a Luke warm.
That's fine,
but now maybe if I wait long enough,
the lukewarm will automatically spontaneously separated.
The hot and cold.
That doesn't seem to happen.
The heap simply seems to flow from heart to call,
but never back from cold to hot,
but flowing from Coulter heart will not violate the law of conservation of
energy.
As long as the same number of calories go from cold to hot,
it doesn't violate anything.
That doesn't seem to happen.
So this can go on and on and on.
There's a large number of things that are allowed but don't happen.
So we cannot explain them with any known laws of physics.
So we elevate that to a new law.
The new law will say,
these things cannot happen,
but you don't have a law that says these things cannot happen.
Right?
That's not a good enough law.
You got to say what things cannot happen.
I got a list of my lung,
the hot and cold when mixed will never separate back into hot and cold aghast.
That genie that got out of the bottle won't go back.
This gas that came on won't back.
There's a whole lot of processes which you call irreversible.
They never seemed to happen backwards.
They only happen forwards and we cannot list all of them.
So you wonder if there is any law.
See Anytime you cannot explain something from prior things,
you elevate that to a law but you like an economic law,
you would not like a law that says the following million things cannot happen.
Yeah.
And it's really amazing that that is one law,
single law that not only is qualitative but it's quantitative that tells you
exactly when somethings can happen and when some things cannot happen and
according to the one single law,
all the things that we say don't happen.
One happen will be forbidden by the law and that's the second law of
thermodynamics.
But what form does it take?
Well,
we will see it introduces certain quantity called entropy about which let's say
right now we don't know anything in the law will simply say the entropy of the
universe will always increase.
You don't have to write it down.
Now I'm going to define the concept.
It'll arise naturally from more thinking that one law,
the entropy will always increase.
The university as a whole is enough to forbid any of these forbidden processes.
In other words,
if the paddle spun the other way and the weight went up in the water cooled
down,
you can show the entropy of the universe would have actually gone down.
That's where that's not allowed.
If you drop a piece of egg an egg,
it comes since splatters all over the floor.
If it rejoined and rose back to your hand,
it won't violate any other principal other than the law of entropy because the
shattered egg has more than repeat and the egg that comes back to your hand
and have hot and cold mix to become lukewarm.
You can show the entropy goes up this way,
but if you went the other way,
entropy will go down and that's not allowed.
So one great law will take care of all these things.
So you've got to ask yourself,
what is the one grade law?
How do we get to it?
Well,
it turns out this great law were discovered by an engineer called carnal.
Here's another thing,
people don't wake up and say,
I'm going to discover a great law.
Uh,
people just go out and do the business and all you need is to have enough sense
to realize when you stumbled on something really great,
it's a car.
And I had a very practical question.
Cardinal was working on engines at the time.
They were working on something like the steam engine.
So steam engine,
you know what happens in the steam engine.
You take some coal,
you set fire to it,
then you boil some water,
it turns into steam and the steam pushes the Pistons and the wheels turn and the
train goes forward.
And that's your steam engine.
What happens in a steam engine,
we can show schematically as follows.
There is a heart reservoir t one that the furnace of your steam engine
did.
You have an engine in which you got some steam,
you got some water that's going to be boiled and it's going to boil because you
taken some heat.
Here's my engine.
It's got some stuff.
Substance inside it could be a gasoline and didn't have the steam engine.
We don't care what happens.
Someone want the feet.
Q one is taken from a hot reservoir
and some of them are,
the work is delivered.
Now here is an engine with as drawn here doesn't violate any of the laws of
physics provided Q one is equal to w than low energy is conserved in practice.
You find that's not have engines work.
The Indian also rejects.
Some of them aren't that he'd Q tube to a lower temperature t to
the lower temperature.
If you look at the steam engine,
if you gone,
have you guys seen a steam engine?
Okay,
if you really go see a steam engine,
you will find this a lot of hot steam coming out of the back or in a car.
You've got exhaust gases coming up.
That's the hot gas emitter.
That atmospheric temperature inside the engine is a very hot place.
So the car emits some heat at the lower temperature,
the steam and didn't image some steam at a lower temperature.
So the work that you can get is really Q one minus Q two is what you can get.
At least in this engine you get Q one minus Q two so we defined a quantity
called efficiency Ada.
Just call the efficiency is what you get divided or what you pay for.
You pay for burning the coal and you get the workout.
The workers of course,
the thing that makes the engine move forward turns into Kennedy energy of the
local model.
That then we can see is Q one minus Q two what you get,
they will get what you pay for.
You can write it as one minus Q two over Q one
so in every engine some heat is taken in,
some of it is converted to work and some of it has rejected
the extent heaters rejected.
The efficiency is less than one because Q two minus over Q and subtract it from
one.
You can ask yourself,
why not build an engine in what you just don't reject any heat downstairs?
Why not take all the heat and convert it to work?
So carnal gave a great argument on the most efficient engine you can build other
words that is an upper limit to the efficiency and there's not one.
So what is it and how are we going to find out?
Well,
he's going to find out what it is,
but he also needs a postulate.
Cartoners postulate is the old version of the second law of thermodynamics.
He didn't talk about entropy.
You can show in the end they are all equivalent,
but car knows law,
which is his own version of the second law,
which says the following.
So a lot too.
According the car.
No.
Yeah,
let me just drive figure then.
That's right.
We we to safety one,
there's not allowed
and says you cannot build an engine.
Okay.
Whose sole effect at the end of the day is to transfer some heat from a quarter
body too.
Hot Body
whose sole effect?
That's very,
very important.
You cannot have a process.
Who sole ethic
is this.
I mean,
I don't feel like writing what this is.
It's what the picture says.
All right?
It doesn't take a genius to have the heat flow the other way you understand if
you want to hit the flow from hot body,
the core body that's trivial,
just connect them with a metal rod and the heat will flow.
The sole effect of that is transfer of heat from the hot to cold.
That's the way the natural order of things,
but cardio is saying you can never build a set of gears and wheels and t
whatever you like so that at the end of the day,
all that has happened is he does flown from cold to hot.
That is going to be taken as a postulate and people are willing to take that as
a reasonable postulate and we want to see what we can get out of the positive.
It turns out it is that postulate that going to control the efficiency of heat
engines put a bound on the efficiency if he vendors,
so dawn did use this,
this is a law.
Now you might say,
well this is how the law it began in the last lawsuit,
modern more sophisticated forms.
Sukarno was not thinking entropy that came later,
but his postulate was,
please grant me this,
which seems to be a fact in nature.
Then from that,
let me talk about heat engines and show you that that is an upper limit to the
efficiency of an engine in particular.
The upper limit is not one.
It's clear to everybody that the limit cannot be more than one.
There's more than one.
You are taking someone more defeat and giving even more amount of work delivered
that violates the first law of thermodynamics,
conservation of energy.
But the fact that you must necessarily reject some heat which you cannot use in
this experiment is the content of car notice result.
So here is the engine.
That car no built,
this is called the car.
No engine
incarnated.
By the way,
look,
don't rely on my graphics.
I mean you have to go look at just about any book you can find in the market.
We will talk about Carnegie engine.
So I'm hitting the mainly tell you the words are not the pictures.
So Cardinal Indian is like this take to
isothermals p one and p two you remember the idea about the curves that are much
steeper draw to Eddie Batek curves like that
than take a gas from a to B to c
to d and back to a that is a carnal engine.
The,
let's see what we are doing in the process.
A,
B,
take the piston with a gas in it slowly lift the grains of sand so it expands to
a volume,
be at the same temperature.
Then having reached B,
you terminally isolate.
The gas is not on top of her as a water temperature.
T one is completely isolated.
Take on even more grains of sand.
Now it's expanding without any energy coming in.
It cools down to t two this is the point.
See
now you put the grains of sand back,
but it's still on a hot reservoir.
T two I met on the cold reservoir t to put the grains of sand back.
Temperature is locked in a teetotal.
You come here,
then you isolate the gas and put more grains of sand bag.
Really come back to a
obviously such a path exists because of the way I saw terminals and I the
barracks in the PV plane.
That's the current cycle.
An important part of the carbon cycle is that it's reversible.
It's reversible because at every stage when it took a grain of sand out,
you can put it back and you can run it backwards so it can also run backwards.
The carnal in gym looks like this.
It is the engine.
It takes them hit Q one from a reservoir.
T one delivers somewhere.
W IRIDEX some heat you to a temperature t two
this is the model of a steam engine
supports you run the car.
No engine backwards.
By the way,
the work done by the carnival engine is this shaded region here and it absorbs
heat in the stage.
Ab doesn't have any heat absorption in the state.
Busy because I diabetic in CD.
It rejects them heat and dia gainers.
No heat transfer,
so he comes in here.
He Won.
He just rejected here.
Q two
if you're on the car,
no engine backwards.
Let me show you what it looks like.
Everything is backwards in the car.
No engine.
If you run it the other way,
some workers put in here some heat.
Q two is taken from the lower reservoir and the heat.
You want to deliver the upper reservoir.
You know what that gadget is?
That's the refrigerator,
so in a refrigerator that's what happens.
You might say,
Hey,
you violated the second law.
You have transferred heat from a cold to hot body,
but it was not the only thing that happened because some compressors somewhere
did some work.
That certainly allowed.
What is not allowed is to have it flow from cold to hot with nothing in
involved.
The second,
second thing to notice is the gas after doing its thing comes back to the
starting point.
That means you can do it over and over and over again in one cycle.
The gas has some heat coming in.
Q one heat rejected Q2,
some work done w and it comes back to where it is and you can go on doing it
many,
many times.
That's where it's useful engine.
If the substance returns to the starting point,
having done some work in return for some heat,
you can do it over and over again and cartons.
Question was what's the efficiency of this engine?
We're going to calculate that now
the efficiency of the engine is Ada is Cuban minus Q two
over Q one
r one minus Q two over Q one
well Q one and Q two are pretty easy to calculate.
Let me tell you why in the process a B,
remember isothermal expansion,
the heat input is the work done
because changing internal energy zero and the work done.
You remember this and our t log the B over the VA?
Yeah.
Similarly acute to asset positive number.
It's an r t two log VC over bebe.
You remember Q two here is defined as a positive number even though it's the
heat rejected.
If you want to get a positive number,
I read the log of the initial overview final so I get a sorry VC or will be d.
Yeah,
so the efficiency now becomes
one minus Q two over Q one you come to one minus t two over t one the log VC or
VB divided by a log.
I'm sorry if VC or be divided by log VB over VA.
Again,
if you cannot follow my script here,
you may have to go back and get the subscript right but don't worry too much
about all the details.
What I want you to know is that the heat input here and the heat rejected here
are all familiar quantities from what I did earlier,
but now here is the punchline.
Ada.
A claim is one minus t two over t one
in other words I'm saying forget this ratio logarithms.
It is just one.
I would show that you of course it's not going to be written without proof,
but
the final answer for efficiency of this engine is one minus t two over t one so
we need to show why VCO would vd is the same as VB Oba.
Well I will.
Did I have that here then for a couple of minutes I'll talk about it then we'll
come back at is you have the discussion
we are trying to show,
I'm going to show you that we see over vd
is the same as VB over VA.
I'm going to show that to you then.
You agree.
If I take the logs and the logs,
we'll cancel.
How do I know this?
Well go back and use the fact that that's an eddy.
That's a nice of thermal process.
That's a nice to tell them at the price of that is an eddy a betting process.
That's an idea about process.
Okay.
This is temporary.
51 this is temperature t two this is a,
B,
c,
d.
No,
somewhere in your notes is the formula that in an eddy robotic process
volume a times temperature,
one to some strange power.
I don't care what the power is,
not going to matter.
It's the same.
Sorry.
Uh,
volume be
times temperature to some power is the same as volume.
See the same,
uh,
temperature t two to some power
because when the process id a we have seen PV to the gamma is constant,
but I told you,
you can also rate it as volume,
times temperature to some power is a constant,
so BMC are correlated this way.
Likewise,
a and D are connected by an antibiotic process,
so you can be sure that the a t that happens to be c one they used to some power
is the same as v The p two raised to some power.
We don't care what the poverty is,
it's probably CV over our outerwear.
CB.
I'm not interested in that.
In fact,
if you go to this top right hand corner,
you can see this volume times t to the power of seaview overwrought,
but it's not important.
The fact that BMC,
Leanna idea baddie curve means that the volume would be and the temperature it'd
be metabolized happens to be t one and the volume at sea and the temperature and
see what happens with the two are connected by this result.
Once I write it down for this idea of adding this idea of Adtech,
know,
divide that by that and that by that and the point is the t one two whatever
poverty it is canceled,
stop and bottom up and bought them and I get the result I wanted which BB over
be a BC over bed.
Once you put that in,
you'll get the final result is one minus t two over t one s
yeah,
no,
there are some things you should know all the times and something you should
know some of the time in something you should have seen at least once the
derivation of the result.
You should have seen at least once in your life whether you can eat and your
head or not.
I'm not interested in but what have I really done?
I've taken an ideal gas and taking it over the cycle and I found out that in
that cycle the ideal gas does function like a very primitive heat engine because
it takes them heat.
Q one rejects them heat cute too and does some work given by the shaded area and
the ratio of work done to heat absorbed in the end happens to be one minus t two
over t one it does not depend on the gas.
It depends only on the upper temperature in the lower temperature.
Another question you can ask is why are you computing the efficiency of this
really primitive and stupid engine winners verus we are interested in real
Indian at GM is going to make or some steam ship is going to make or some Indian
is going to make.
We will show next time that this efficiency is a theoretical maximum.
I will show you the next time that no engine can beat the car,
no engine,
no engine can be as good.
It can be as good but cannot be better than the car engine and that's what makes
the dissolved important.
It's a lot like a relativity example that to show you why time slows down and a
moving frame.
I took a very stupid clock where the clock ticks because light beam goes up and
down.
That's not your idea for clock,
but in that clock,
if you can see why it slows down,
you know that every clock has to slow down because all plugs in a moving rocket
must run at the same rate.
Otherwise,
you can compare the two clocks and find out you're moving.
Likewise,
if you take a very primitive engine or you can show that that engine is the most
efficient engine you are done,
because that's going to put an upper limit on efficiency.
So I'll come back and I'll tell you next time why no Indian can be this engine
and why hidden in this result is the notion of entropy.